Vale, voy a iniciar grabación. A ver,
y voy a
Vale, este es el cuatro.
Configuración de entrega. Está activada.
El caso es que está activada, eh, la
entrega.
Vale, pues le tenemos que decir una
fecha a tope.
Claro, ahí está.
Eh,
bueno, pues podemos poner, a ver,
podemos poner el cinco.
Cinco es domingo. El domingo que viene
tenemos cinco o 12. Y yo al a mí el 12
no me gusta poner las cosas para para
que enviéis porque porque
vamos, vas ahí a contrarreloj con el
puente y tampoco es tampoco es plan.
Prefiero que sea el 15, el 5 o el 15,
pero como esto vamos a probarlo
simplemente que no es no es para
calificar,
simplemente para que cojáis mano con el
con el packet tracer. Y luego ya
pondremos un ejercicio bien de de paquet
tracer para para evaluable,
¿vale? Pero primero vamos a hacer esto,
estos dos que creo que son bastante
interesantes.
Vale, a ver, configuración de entrega,
requiere pulsar botón envío, no no no y
calificación que no tenga. Vale, no
quiero calificación aquí.
A ver.
La cuatro lo he cambiado y en teoría os
debería de dejar
enviar.
Si podéis alguien actualizar la página,
mirar el cuatro a ver si a ver si os
deja.
No,
no, no te deja.
pone eh apertura cierre, pero no pone la
pestaña para mandarlo.
Claro. Vale,
vale. Pues ya daré con la tecla.
De momento vamos a usar el el tema de de
Gmail, ¿vale? Y luego podemos ir
enviando en la en la carpeta esa que
tenéis que tenéis permisos de edición.
Recordar ponerle nombres
y también recordar que no es evaluable,
o sea, simplemente para que vayáis
cogiendo cogiendo destreza con con el
programa
y veáis y vayáis viendo cómo se va cómo
se cómo se m cómo se despliegan redes.
Vale, ayer nos quedamos aquí en
certificación de instalación. Eh, espera
que active el chat. Vale.
Certificación de instalación.
Vale, porque estuvimos viendo.
Vale, ¿os acordáis los subsistemas
que estuvimos viendo todo esto? Se cómo
dividir las redes para que sean más
óptimas.
etcétera, etcétera. Estuvimos así
pasando por encima. Es un poco un
algo así como cuando te enfrentas al
excel
cómo cómo me monto el trabajo este para
para que para hacerlo de la manera más
óptima, ¿no? Pues sería algo así, o sea,
plantearnos
eh
plantearnos maneras de cómo hacer las
cosas antes de antes de iniciarlas.
Vale, certificación de la instalación.
El correcto funcionamiento del sistema
de cableado es tan importante que en
muchas instalaciones se exige la
certificación de cada uno de los cables,
es decir, se compara la calidad de cada
cable con unos patrones de referencia
propuestos por un estándar. Mira,
podemos ver un vídeo también de que nos
habla también de todo esto de
tipos de cables que sí que están están
los materiales de la asignatura,
¿vale? En el caso de los cables de
cobre, la norma comúnmente utilizada es
la ANCIA ATSB67
del año 95.
La norma EIA Tía 568 y suivalente norma
ISO. Eso sí que os suena más, ¿no? Las
normas ISO. Eso sí que habréis visto por
ahí.
Norma ISO y S11801.
De hecho, o sea, nos venimos aquí a ISO,
bueno, la buscamos y
tengo esto.
[Música]
Vale,
aquí sería un No, no nos vamos a ir a la
Wikipedia porque la Wikipedia la habrá
pillado aquí.
Vale.
Están. A ver. Y eso uno. A ver.
Mm.
Es puñetero esto del zoom, ¿eh?
Vale, la ISO lo que estábamos viendo.
pone que está retirada.
Detada la norma ciclo de vida
anteriormente retirada
y ahora,
¿vale? se creó en el 95
y su equivalente norma
y a que nos va a venir a
lo puesto bien, ¿verdad? Eso. A ver.
Lo que os quería comentar es que siempre
que veáis un
una norma tal, o sea, es un catálogo de
especificaciones
relativos a tal y que y que vienen,
o sea, es un documento que podéis
consultar realmente la norma esa.
Siempre que veáis una una norma podéis
ir a consultarla. Está posiblemente está
retirada porque porque se ha añadido
otra posterior. Lo que pasa que en la
página no os lo pone.
Vale, eso es lo que estaba lo que lo que
quería ver.
Estado
iso y vale lo que se vale lo que ha
cambiado es la denominación entiendo que
antes se llamaba iso sí que se lo se lo
han quitado.
se mantiene la numeración
y se le añade las islas estas y eso va,
bueno, sea el pequeño apunte, ¿vale? La
certificación de una instalación
significa que todos los cables que la
componen cumplen con estos patrones de
referencia y por tanto se tiene la
garantía de que cumplan con las
exigencias para las que fueron
diseñados, ¿vale? A modo de ejemplo, los
parámetros comúnmente probados para los
cables UTP de categoría 5, no hemos
entrado todavía a ver cables, que eso lo
vamos a ver,
lo veremos a continuación en si no hoy
en las siguientes clases,
¿vale? Los cables UTP categoría 5 y
clase D son el mapa de cableado, la
longitud del segmento que no debe
superar los 90 m, la atenuación
de la línea y el nex, eh, que
proporciona una medida de la
autoinducción electromagnética de las
líneas de unas líneas en otras.
¿Vale? nos las consideraciones de esta
norma especifican los siguientes
elementos: requerimientos mínimos para
el cableado de telecomunicaciones,
topología de la red y distancias máximas
recomendadas, parámetros determinados
del rendimiento. Estas normas incluyen
otras como la TSB 36A que determina, a
ver, es a nivel muy técnico, ¿vale? Pero
sí que sí que cuando tenéis que
desplegar un una red, pues os tenéis que
que ceñir a a todo este tipo de de
normativas.
Eh, determinar las características de
los cables de pares trenzados de
Cómnios. La norma TSB40A que indica las
características
de los conectores RJ45 y sus conexiones
o la norma TSB 53
que especifica los cables blindados de
150 y sus conectores.
La organización internacional TIA EA
contempla un conjunto de estándares con
el cableado estructurado que se exponen
en la siguiente tabla.
Vale, pues aquí tenéis la tabla
para la
de los estándares,
¿vale? Dispositivos certificadores,
¿vale? La certificación del cable se
realiza con una maquinaria especial que
realiza los test apropiados de manera
automática o semiautomática.
Existen cuatro tipos de instrumentos
para la medición de parámetros de redes
que en orden creciente de complejidad
son los siguientes: comprobadores de
continuidad del cable. ¿Habéis
alguna vez habéis utilizado un
comprobador de estos de continuidad?
Yo sí, vale.
Para un cable de móvil, o sea, de móvil
eh fijo,
sí, que ibas a hacer ahí una chapucilla,
¿no? De de ponerle el
el cabezal y has mirado en un extremo a
ver cuál cuál de los dos es el que,
o sea, para no liarla, básicamente,
para no ponerlo al revés, ¿no? Lo que
vayas solar
est que que estuvo sin un funcionario
una tarde entera porque no sabía
hacerlo, pero sí.
Bueno,
pero ahora ya te pones si lo haces.
Sí,
claro.
Vale. Comprobadores de de continuidad
del cable. un comprobador de continuidad
del cable lo que nos va lo que nos
proporciona es es eso es lo que dice
Jorge, o sea, ¿qué cable qué extremo del
cable se eh imaginar que tenéis dos
cables, los dos son los dos son del
mismo color y van juntos unidos?
¿Vale? que eh
con el con el comprobador de continuidad
lo que haces es pones un en un extremo
una punta del comprobador y en el otro
extremo la otra punta y compruebas que
hay una continuidad de un extremo a
otro, ¿vale? El que te pite o el que te
o el que te imita unas un una señal
visual o o sea, esto ya es cada cada
aparato es diferente. Generalmente
pitan, ¿vale? Hacen pit pi pit.
Pero hay otros que parpadean, otros que
que encienden una luz, otr, o sea, hay
1000.
Lo normal que pite,
lo pones en un extremo, lo pones en otro
y pruebas en las dos en las dos en los
dos cables y el que no pite es que no
tiene continuidad con el otro extremo.
El que sí pita es el que tiene
continuidad con el otro extremo.
Vale. verificadores de cables,
instrumentos de verificación
certificador y analizadores de redes.
¿Vale? Al comprobar la continuidad se se
eh, a ver, se puede comprobar también la
resistencia que tiene esa continuidad,
¿vale? Eso ya me imagino que entramos
ahí en el terreno de los de un aparato
especial que sirve para certificar un
cable. Claro, obviamente no te va a
servir un
polímetro de del chino, ¿vale? O uno que
puedas tener tú de andar por casa.
Ahora realmente, o sea, si os gusta esto
de de la electrónica y tal, ahora hay
unos unos aparatos de medición
estupendos
por poco, por bastante poco, que incluso
te detectan.
No, claro, no es que no sé hasta qué
nivel habéis habéis toqueteado este este
tema, ¿vale?
Pero algunos hasta tienen detector de
detector de de cables en por dentro de
las paredes.
O sea, tú lo pasas por la pared y te
dice, "Vale, la línea
aquí estoy notando eh que hay tensión,
¿vale? dentro de la
en este trozo de pared y empieza a pitar
y y eh los habréis visto muchos que
tienen un selector,
pero los nuevos que están saliendo lo
que son suelen ser automáticos y ellos
te detectan la medición
que que vamos, o sea, se ponen en modo
automático, ¿vale? y te y te tanto la
continuidad como la impedancia como la
la resistencia,
¿no?
[Música]
A ver, esto sería
multímetro.
Multimetro digital.
Vale, esto es esto es a lo que me
refiero, ¿vale? Multímetro digital,
que es una herrami Los de los que venís
de primero el año pasado sí que lo
habréis tocado, ¿no, Álvaro?
Sí, esto lo utilizamos para para
comprobar todos los cables y todo eso,
¿sí? No,
y sí que lo estuvisteis ahí usando.
Vale. Y yo lo que os decía
es, a ver,
automático.
Estos automáticos, aparte de que los
puedes poner en modo manual,
no son. Bueno, este no sé yo que
a ver, me decantaría por por algo así
ya, incluso por este,
¿vale? Por es estos son automáticos y lo
que te hacen es que te detectan un, o
sea, tú lo pones, te pones a medio una
resistencia y te está dando los valores
de esa resistencia. O sea, no tienes que
ir que obviamente sí que también puedes
puedes seleccionar lo que quieres medir,
pero por defecto vienen configurados
para que los utilices sin tener que que
elegir lo que quieras medir. ¿Vale?
Sería la evolución un poquito de
de todo esto. Se ve más adelante en los
en la
creo que esto es en la otra asignatura,
en la de en la de montaje,
¿vale?
Como veis, tampoco son excesivamente
caros, o sea,
por Amazon 35, pues tampoco está tan
mal.
Este es que este lo veo demasiado Seguro
te te ponen 30 € de gastos de envío o
algo así,
¿no? Pone sin coste. No sé, demasiado
barato. Hasta lo veo, ¿eh?
funda y todo.
Bueno,
vale,
vale. Estábamos en los dispositivos
certificadores que de comprobadores de
contenido del cable nos hemos ido a todo
esto, pero bueno.
Los fabricantes de estos dispositivos
sus en sus manuales los modos de
operación facilitan
o o proporcionan sus manuales los modos
de operación correctos para efectuar
todas las medidas.
Aquí solo mencionamos algunas
generalidades. Los aparatos de medida se
componen de dos dispositivos que que
normalmente se instalan, uno el
principio del cable, dispositivo activo,
y otro al final, dispositivo pasado, a
modo determinador.
Un agente activo,
un agente activo envía unas señales muy
específicas por el cable a certificar y
el pasivo devuelve estas señales para
que sean leídas de de nuevo por el
dispositivo activo. En función de la
diferencia entre lo que emitió y lo que
ha recibido por los diferentes pares del
cable, el agente activo averigua los
parámetros eléctricos del cable
construido. Si se comparan estos valores
con los de referencia especificados en
las normativas, concluiremos si el cable
es o no válido.
Vale, a ver, vamos a poner esto.
Instalación del centro de proceso de
datos.
Muchas de las instalaciones de diosa
naturaleza, no solo de red, pueden
realizarse simultáneamente,
puesto que suelen ser profesionales
distintos los que acometan cada parte de
la instalación, el estricista,
instaladores de cable, certificadores,
aire acondicionado, etcétera.
Una vez que las canalizaciones están
instaladas y probadas, comienza la
instalación de servidores y dispositivos
de red.
A partir de este más se podrá empezar a
probar los servicios de red antes de
llegar al régimen de explotación.
En el centro de proceso de datos es muy
importante cuidar la accesibilidad a los
equipos,
de modo que se pueda actuar rápidamente
en caso de cualquier avería.
¿Vale? Las consolas de los servidores
tienen que estar bien protegidas, ya que
quien tiene acceso a una consola
podrá manipular fácilmente el servidor
al que pertenece.
Los lugares en los que se instalan
servidores o que contienen puntos
neurálgicos de las comunicaciones
deben ser lugares de estancia cómoda,
aunque cerrados bajo llave. Es
importante esto. Frecuentemente, el
acceso a estos lugares se realiza bajo
la supervisión de algún sistema de
control de presencia con tarjetas de
banda magnética, reconocimiento
biométrico
u otros sistemas de identificación
especialmente seguros.
¿Vale? Generalmente en las empresas
normales ya no esto hablamos de quizá
grandes empresas y tal, pero en una
empresa de 200 trabajadores y así lo que
hay es una llave y ya está. O sea, lo
normal es que te encuentres que eso está
bajo llave, o sea, que no que vayas ahí
con la tarjeta magnética y tal, eso no
es lo normal,
pero sí, vamos, o sea,
más seguridad así.
El proceso de instalación de un CPD
es muy delicado por la gran cantidad de
tareas críticas que requiere, por lo que
debe diseñarse con su cuidado, siempre
ayudados de planos y una buena
documentación.
Vale, pero es que en el planito este no
nos aparece, ¿eh?
Claro, el servidor y tal podría estar
aquí, pero pero estaría bien que
estuviera, ¿no? Esto es Ah, vale, vale.
No, vale, no, que me estaba me estaba
liando. Vale, vale. Sí, sería toda la
zona. Esto serían racks.
Vale, la parte de delante, la parte
trasera. Vale, vale, vale. Debido a las
necesidades de seguridad crecientes,
cada vez se hace más importante un buen
diseño de un centro de proceso de datos.
Entre los factores que hay que eh que
tener en cuenta para este diseño están
los siguientes.
Aire acondicionado,
o sea, ahí es interesante que que
siempre esté a la misma temperatura
todo,
tanto verano como invierno.
Doble cometida eléctrica, si fuera
posible, de varias compañías
suministradas distintas. ¿Por qué? ¿Por
qué creéis que tenemos que tener una
doble acometida eléctrica
o cuál sería el papel de una doble
acometida eléctrica?
Pues evitar que si falla una tenemos la
otra.
Básicamente es eso,
redundancia las comunicaciones con el
exterior, cables de red, fibras ópticas,
telefonía, etcétera, si es posible
también de diferentes compañías,
¿vale? nos está diciendo eso qué, o sea,
realmente estamos implementando como
medidas de seguridad
a la hora de de implementar todo, o sea,
de desplegar, ¿vale? Este centro proceso
de datos
montacargas altura y anchura de puerta
suficiente para introducir las máquinas
que alojan el CPD seguridad de acceso
controlada por puntos de presencia
vigilancia, alarma, seguridad contra
incendios, control de parámetros
medioambientales, temperatura y humedad.
O sea, yo cuando os decía que lo que te
vas a encontrar en las empresas,
eh, a ver si tienes la suerte de
trabajar o desarrollar en un centro de
proceso de datos,
desarrollarlo a nivel de técnico de
sistemas,
pues estupendo, pero o sea, lo normal es
que nos encontremos en empresas que
tienen un cuartito con su rack y lo sumo
dos
y poco más.
O sea, y en ese y en esos armar en esos
RATS van a tener pues pues todos los
dispositivos que te sirven para para la
red informática, para la intranet de la
de la empresa,
¿vale? Lo normal que nos vamos a
encontrar aquí en Valencia va a ser eso.
Luego un centro de proceso de datos y
que es es otra historia. Y bueno, a ver,
sí que tiene que estar diseñado de de
esta manera,
¿vale? Control de parámetros mediamente.
O sea, lo que os quiero decir es que
luego en en empresas no tan no tan
tochas, no sé.
A ver, se hace, no quiero decir que
salgan las cosas mal,
¿vale? Lo que digo es que
muchas veces se intenta abaratar y si
abaratas hm vas poniendo
vas poniendo cosas que a lo mejor no son
chapuzas, pero sí que hacen el apaño.
No sé si me explico.
Sí,
vale.
que tú a lo mejor le presentas a un
cliente un presupuesto y le dices 15,000
y dice, "Ostras, imposible." Pues ya te
toca empezar a rebajar.
que si la regleta que voy a poner el
rack, que si esto de aquí, que si esto
de allá, que si la el acceso a la a la
sala de servidores, aunque tengas solo
un rack, da igual, sería la sala de
servidores. Eso sí o sí interesa que no
esté en el medio de algún sitio, en el
medio de un pasillo, ahí al alcance de
todos. Eso interesa que esté
resguardado, resguardado bajo llave
mínimo.
Luego ya si le quieres meter un acceso
por banda magnética, por huella, por lo
que sea, pues ya todo eso lo va a
encarecer. Si le quieres meter un
sistema de videovigilancia también lo va
a encarecer.
Vale, el control de parámetros
medioambientales, temperatura y humedad,
cuadros de distribución eléctrica y
dependientes y seguros, falsos suelos y
techos. ¿Para qué? para distribuir las
todo el cableado.
Vale, estuvimos hablando que por el
suelo es una muy buena opción de llevar
los de llevar el cableado por el techo
también, por supuesto. Sai y generadores
de corriente. Creo que SA sí que sí que
estuvimos a eh sí que lo hablamos, ¿no?
En alguna clase lo que lo que era.
Sí,
vale.
Y son caros. Sí, es un sistema de de
alimentación interrumpida
ininterrumpida, perdón. Y bueno, lo que
lo que es es básicamente algo que te
salva
que te salva durante un tiempo, pero
claro, es limitado porque porque llevan
una, o sea, es como un es como una power
band realmente, pero a lo tocho, ¿vale?
Que te va a servir en el momento que se
va la luz.
para funcionar, para dar dar energía. En
este caso serían servidores,
¿eh? Como sabemos que eso es limitado,
esa energía que almacena, pues aquí lo
que sí que tenemos que contemplar es
generadores de corriente.
O sea, no podemos dejar que esos
que esos eh
que esos eh servidores del centro de
proceso de datos se apaguen. O sea, eso
no podemos
esa sería el objetivo, ¿vale? Generador
de corriente. ¿Qué se os ocurre como
generador de corriente?
Pues pueden ser generadores eh puestos
en la azotea que
que se que vayan con combustible con
diésel perfectamente. O sea, básicamente
sería algo así como los
como los estos como los de las obras.
El sistema de placas solares también
sería sería interesante,
¿vale? Que estuviera comunicado el
almacenamiento de las placas solares,
que estuviera comunicado con con la red
eh interna eléctrica
y en caso de apagónital que que su
prioridad fuera esta sala, la sala de
del proceso de datos.
Vale, el consumo energético de un CPD es
muy elevado, o sea, imaginad todo estos
son racks de 2 m por lo menos.
Eh, imaginad el consumo que tiene cada
cada
armario de estos.
Y si y si el Sai falla y hay un corto,
¿qué pasaría con todos los RX? Si el SAI
falla,
o sea, el SA falla, ¿te refieres a que a
que deja de a que se le agota la
batería, por ejemplo,
sí? O sea, que queen al side y no les
llega eh corriente a todo el servidor,
pues ahí debe de haber un sistema de un
sistema alternativo eléctrico
en el que que te detecte ese fallo.
Generalmente los sí que sí que te
puentean.
Los llevan un software interno, ¿vale?
para gestionar todo esto. Depende del SA
también, o sea, si te compras ahí uno de
uno ahí baratillo, pues igual no lo
lleva tan sofisticado, pero
pero que detecta cuando hay un fallo,
generalmente un fallo no hay que puede
ser a que puede ser debido a que se le a
que la vida útil de esas baterías esté
agotando.
Eso es lo más lo más lógico en el
momento de detecta que que está
fallando, pues
o sea, ahí sería ahí está empezaría a
[__] de electricidad, o sea, dejaría de
lado el SA, por ejemplo.
O sea, lo que tenemos que pensar es que
esto es un sistema automático, o sea,
esto lo tenemos que configurar
eh de forma automática.
¿Cómo funciona? O sea, te llega la
corriente eléctrica al SA y el SA está
enchufado al
estaría estaría enchufado a esto, al
a lo a los a las regletas del rack. Si
falla
si falla al side, entrarían los los
generadores de corriente o la o la luz
directa.
O sea, es que depende las
configuraciones de cada
de cada eso, pero sí que lo tenemos que
contemplar como un sistema automático
en el que si vemos que un, o sea, un
castillo naipe, si vemos que uno no se
que se está cayendo una carta, pues la
otra va a ir detrás. Entonces tenemos
que que tener previsto todos estos
escenarios.
Vale, como es realmente lo que estábamos
diciendo que es un consumo muy muy
elevado que proponer maquinaria de bajo
consumo eléctrico, genere menos calor y
consiga un doble ahorro económico, menor
consumo de energía eléctrica, menor
consumo de aire acondicionado. O sea,
optimizar ahí en lo que pongamos ya no
solo lo que son las luces, las, o sea,
la iluminación, obviamente la pondremos
la pondremos LED, ¿no? Vamos a poner
lámparas intradcentes o
de
o estas otras que las halógenas, ¿vale?
Eso va a consumir un montonazo, no tiene
sentido hoy en día,
pero bueno, nos estaba hablando de algo
más de los aparatos de aire
acondicionado, pues poner el
los que o sea que que estén optimizados,
¿no? Podrían ser aparatos inverter o no
sé.
Realmente no vamos a tener un split eh
ahí puesto, o sea, sería un aire
acondicionado por conductos.
La máquina no estaría, la máquina de de
aire acondicionado no estaría en el
propio espacio. O sea, lo que tendríamos
sería el difusor.
posiblemente su instalación
vendría,
o sea, estaría, sí, obviamente estaría
estaría en el exterior, sí, no vamos a
poner el interior, pero sí que
tendríamos en el techo los lo que son
los, bueno, lo habréis visto, ¿no? En en
multitud de comercios y oficinas, los
los
aires acondicionados se instalan en el
techo,
¿vale? tiene una serie de,
o sea, es como un split pero puesto en
el techo realmente.
Limpieza en los en los equipos
informáticos es super importante. Polvo
es malo,
es conductivo, además.
Y aquí nos habla un poquito de la
gestión de residuos.
de su forma leyes directivas para el
caso de residuos electrónicos o
eléctricos que tienen como objetivo
reducir la cantidad de residuos,
la pelíc de sus componentes o fomentar
la reutilización de los dispositivos de
desecho. Para lograr estos objetivos se
establecen unas normas que se aplican a
la fabricación de los productos o bien a
su carrecta gestión ambiental cuando se
conviertan en residuos.
O sea, hm, claro, cuando nosotros
eh nos deshacemos, por ejemplo, de un SA
que ya no funciona, ¿no? ¿Qué hacemos?
¿Lo tiramos a basura? No, eso hay que
eso hay que gestionarlo todo esto. Ya no
solo el site, que sería lo más
contaminante quizás, pero un un
servidor, por ejemplo, un servidor que
ya no
que no lo vayamos a porque se que no lo
vayamos a usar porque sea se ha quedado
anticuado, eso no lo vamos a tirar a la
basura. Llamaremos a una empresa que se
encargue de ello, ¿vale? posiblemente
quite el procesador, quite los
procesadores, los
hm a lo mejor los reutiliza, los
reutiliza vendiéndolos a otros sitios,
no lo sé. O sea, esto ya es
es un poquito especular, ¿vale? con que
pero sí que no vamos a cogerlo. H bueno,
lo que hacéis en en vuestra casa, se os
rompe algo y lo tiráis,
lo tiráis ahí a la basura o qué es lo
que
o lo lleváis a un punto limpio, que
sería lo más lo más lógico.
Vale, hay muchas categorías de
resudiatos
eléctricos y electrónicos, además de los
equipos informáticos como son
electrodomésticos
de consumo, dispositivos de alumbrado,
herramientas, puetas, aparatos médicos,
instrumentos de vigilancia y control,
máquinas expendedoras.
Para el caso de equipos de informática y
telecomunicaciones se prevé la gestión
de los siguientes grandes ordenadores.
A ver, para el caso de equipos de
informática y telecomunicación se
prevestión de los siguientes e eh e
incluyendo central pantalla tampoco
común format
ya, pero no me dice ahí nada
final.
Vale,
la directiva eh 76768
de la Unión Europea ordena que los
usuarios
de estos
de estos elementos
utilizados en sus hogares deberá
entregarlos cuando se deshagan de ellos
para que sean gestionados correctamente.
La entrega de los RA eee será sin coste
alguno para el último poseedor y podrá
realizarse en los puntos de recogida
previstos en su área geográfica o
siempre que adquiera un aparato que sea
equivalente se realiza las mismas.
¿Habéis ido alguna vez a un punto limpio
a llevar algo?
Sí. ¿Has visto que hay un montón de de
Claro, a nosotros como a nosotros como
nos gusta esto se nos van los ojos ahí
realmente. No sé si os pasa a vosotros,
a mí yo cuando he ido digo, "Pero, ¿cómo
han tirado esto?"
Vale, te encuentras ahí cosas que dices,
"Madre mía, si me dejaran a mí
cacharrear aquí,
¿vale? Porque te encuentras, oye, a lo
mejor te encuentras ahí que han tirado
portátiles, han tirado
monitores, que vete a saber si
funcionan, si no funcionan o si es que
simplemente se han cansado de ellos y
los han y los han llevado al punto
limpio.
Realmente con hay
con el tema de de informática hay mucho
desconocimiento, eh, realmente a lo
mejor por un cable que no te acopla
tiras el aparato. Por un
cable que no te acopla, un cable que se
ha roto, no sabes realmente, a lo mejor
no te funciona un portátil simplemente
porque no porque no disipa el calor,
porque está porque está lleno de polvo,
está lleno de pelos de porque tienes una
mascota.
No sé si habéis abierto alguna vez el PC
un amigo que tenga mascota y tal y diga,
"Ostras, eh,
esto
está esto está muy lleno de de pelos de
o de polvo, ¿no? Y esto no te se te
calienta más de la cuenta por esa
cuestión.
O sea, hay gente que coge eso y
directamente lo tira. Esto no va ya los
viejos no va. Vale.
Impresoras que a lo mejor no van porque
tienen el rodillo que se que está sucio.
Las impresoras es que claro, eso es otra
eso es otra historia. Son de son de su
padre y a su madre, pero
pero sí sí
a veces por cosas tantas tiramos tiramos
aparatos.
Vale. Eh, esto serían lo que
en lo que se refiere a la a la unidad
dos, el cableado.
Si queréis vemos
a ver,
hay un ejercicio de cables, ¿no? Pero si
no lo vamos a poner.
Un segundo, eh, que voy a voy a mirar
las
materiales de la espatura. Vale, estamos
en
Estamos en la unidad dos.
Tenemos el material este de cables
trenzados.
A ver,
vale, voy a descargarlo y así por lo
menos vemos estos tipos de cables.
de cables de parte entrads. El otro día,
Jorge y bueno, Álvaro, que estabais
aquí, sí que estuvimos mirando
mirando cable que tenía aquí en el
cajón.
Y a ver,
lo que sí que estuvimos viendo era un
cable cruzado, bueno, y luego el cable,
un cable que se había configurado como
cruzado, pero sí que est lo que sí que
estuvimos viendo es que era
era este tipo de cable, ¿vale? Es
primero el cable UTP que no lleva
no va pantallado,
o sea, cuando va pantallado, vale,
voy a Vale, cable UTP, esto es lo que
visteis el otro día,
¿vale? que son siglas de, bueno, cable
de par trenzado sin blindaje.
Este tipo de cables contienen sus pares
trenzados pares.
Se refiere al cable, el cable naranja y
cable naranja blanco, cable verde, verde
blanco, cable azul azul blanco, cable
marrón marrón blanco.
Contienen sus pares trenzados sin
blindar. Y si veis se repite también en
estos, pero luego la luego la no, o sea,
luego van apantallados. Bueno, vamos a a
seguir con este, ¿vale? Este tipo de
cables contienen sus pares trenzados sin
blindar, es decir, entre cada una de las
parejas de cables no existe un medio de
separación que los aisle de las otras
parejas,
¿vale? estarían todos los pares metidos,
van trenzados y metidos en la en la en
lo que es la funda exterior.
Vale, creo que se ve ahí, ¿no? Se se ve
un poquillo ahí en la en la imagen.
Tú, Álvaro, que que el año pasado sí que
sí que utilizaste esto,
¿vale? Y estuvisteis clipando y tal.
Sí que viste que que eso, o sea, que que
van los pares ahí trenzados. Tienes que
tener cuidado. Si lo depende como lo
cortes también te puedes llevar por
delante.
Sí, yo corté algunos mal y los tuve que
tirar.
Sí,
son algunos dificilillos.
Os oigo bajísimo, de verdad. Yo no sé si
es el debe es que debe ser esto, ¿eh?
A ver. Vale, esto tiene aquí un azcla.
Es que debe estar el volumen bajado del
monitor.
Ahora mejor.
No, no, no ha tocado nada.
Ahora te lo
te lo digo. A ver, eh,
es audi. Sí,
no, esto no es audio.
[Música]
Vale, brillo. Quiero
hacer color.
Estaba
superbajo.
¿Podéis hablar ahora alguien que lo
pruebe?
Hola, hola, hola, hola.
Vale, ahora se ve o mejor, bastante
mejor.
Lo voy a poner a tope. Está vale a 90.
Vale.
Y vale, es que os oía superbajito.
Vale,
vale. Estábamos casi siempre se
utilizado. Pues eso, lo que lo que
hablábamos que que me decías que que eso
que te habías cargado algunos, ¿no,
Álvaro? Con cortando el otro.
Sí, alguno que se me pasó de la mano.
Vale, vale. Casi siempre utilizado en
redes locales de corta distancia, ya que
al estar más expuesto, la señal se iría
degradando si no se introduce un
repetidor de señal cada poco. Estos
cables son de bajo coste y normalmente
tienen una impedancia característica de
de 100.
Costa, estamos hablando de
poco el metro.
Vamos a ver precios también.
A ver,
venga, voy a poner PC componentes. Va.
Y PC también. Ah.
Una bobina de 305 m.
134.
Una bobina de 100 m, 86, o sea, a 86
céntimos, ¿no? 87 el metro.
UTPK, categoría 5E. Claro que luego
están las categorías. A ver, este
categoría seis, categoría 5co.
¿Veis? sin blindaje.
Eso lo veremos ahí dependiendo de
Vamos a ver.
Vale, son baratos, ¿eh? O sea,
no sé si habéis comprado cable
eléctrico, pero vamos, nada que ver.
Esto realmente es bastante bastante
económico. Vale, estos cables con los
que se ha utilizado la red telefónica
doméstica en dos pares trenzados con
conector RJ11. ¿Habéis visto cómo son
los cables de la red? No sé si tenéis
teléfono fijo en casa,
pero bueno, la roseta
de de RJ11
es muy similar a RJ45, a la RJ45, pero
pero es más estrecha
y lo que lleva es eso, dos pares
trenzados,
¿vale? para hacia el conector RJ11, que
es hm es la versión teléfono de del
RJ45.
Vale, el cable F, espera, el FTP.
En este caso tenemos un cable cuyos
trenzados están separados entre ellos
por un sistema básico basado en plástico
o material no conductor.
Creo que ahí se ve un poquito la
diferenciación.
Lo veis que van encasulados los los
pares,
¿vale? están separados entre ellos con
un sistema básico basado en plástico,
material no conductor. En este caso el
apantallamiento no es individual, sino
que envuelve a todo el grupo de pares, o
sea, el apantallado sería esto
y ahí sí que lleva una separación.
De este tocasteis, Álvaro, alguno o
tocasteis solo de este más caros.
Tocamos más los de los de abajo, creo
yo. Los FTP.
¿Cuál? Estos
los FTP, ¿no? Los ese, el de abajo.
Este,
sí, ese.
Vale, vale.
Creo no me acuerdo muy bien. Vale, vale,
vale.
posible que este salga más barato.
Metros pone 100, ¿no? 100 met.
No sé, es que me parece más económico
este que el otro. No tiene sentido.
Vale,
estamos aquí conchar están separados
entre ellos por un sistema básico basado
en plástico material no conductor. En
este caso el apantallamiento no es
individual sino global que envuelve a
todo el grupo de pares trenzados. Está
construido en aluminio. No cuenta con
tan buenas prestaciones como los cables
STP, pero sí mejoran a los UTP. En
cuanto a distancia y aislamiento. Son
muy utilizados
y utilizan el conector RJ45 y su
impedancia característica de 120 gos,
¿vale? Los cables STP
van apantallados en sus pares. Pues este
no lo tocasteis ya, imagino.
No, eso ya no.
Eso ya no. Pasamos al siguiente cable de
la lista cuyas siglas eh españolen
blindado individual. En este caso
ya sí que tenemos cada uno de los pares
trenzados rodeados de una cubierta de
protección normalmente hecha de
aluminio. Estos cables se utilizan en
redes que requieren más altas
prestaciones, como los nuevos estándares
Ethernet, en donde se necesita un alto
ancho de banda, latencias muy bajas y
bajísimas tasas de error de bit.
Son cables más caros que los anteriores
y permiten trazar mayores distancias sin
necesidad de repetidor. Su impegancia
característica de 150.
Vale, son cables hechos, pero queremos
una bobina.
mucha diferencia
ese. Ah, es que este no.
Bueno,
vamos a
100 met 114. Tampoco se va.
Vale, veis ahí lo la diferencia,
¿no? Pues no está muy caro, ¿eh? Este
tampoco.
Un neurete con 14 el metro.
Vale,
vale. Se utilizan, bueno, lo que
decíamos, ¿vale? Es de
son cables más caros que los anteriores
y permiten trazar mayores distancias sin
necesidad de repetidor características
de 150.
Estos cables generalmente se utilizan
con conectores RJ49.
Conectores RJ49. A ver,
RJ
49.
A ver si lo tienen aquí.
Esto es un adaptador, pero bueno.
No podemos ver si nos de cerca.
Vale, este sería
Pero quiero más info. A ver, a ver si en
el otro, si en el PC compar lo tenemos.
RJ
49.
Lo quería que lo vieseis ahí con más
detalle.
Vale, el cable SSTP o cable de pares
trenzados, laminados,
blindado individual,
es un cable con una estructura propia de
un cable STP,
es decir, con cada uno de los pares
recubierto por aluminio, pero a su vez
también encontramos un [__] global
alrededor del material, o sea, que sería
este de aquí,
¿vale? Que este no lo lleva. El que
hemos visto antes sí que sería un este
que estaba aquí en en el en PCBX.
Está aquí. Aquí
o no sé dónde lo hemos visto. Creo que
ha sido aquí
el que hemos visto antes. No,
pues nada.
Vale. Eh,
vale, pero a su vez también encontramos
un foro global alrededor del material
LSH.
Este cable,
este cable es el de más altas
prestaciones con excelente protección
frente al frecuencias y gran capacidad
de transmisión.
alargar distancia. Su pantalla global
irá de forma
general conectada a la toma de tierra de
los equipos para eliminar
tensiones residuales. Por supuesto, es
el cable de mayor coste de la lista.
Y luego tenemos el cable ST SFTP,
cable laminado apantallado. Este cable
se basa en la construcción del cable
FTP, o sea, este de aquí.
Vale, en el que
pero en el apantallamiento global se le
ha añadido una malla metálica
alrededor para aumentar el aislamiento
de este cable. Al igual que el anterior,
esta lámina irá conectada a la toma de
tierra.
Si lo veis, está tanto en este en el
STP,
en el
en el SSP
sería esta de aquí, o sea, aquí sería
esta de aquí para la toma de tierra,
aquí esta
y aquí está.
Esta lámina irá conectada a toda tierra
en los dispositivos que la tengan. Estos
mejoran las prestaciones de un cable
FTP, aunque siguen siendo inferiores a
los cables STP.
¿Vale? Y a ver, tenemos
eh,
a ver, vale,
vale, si queréis cogemos y hacemos un
ejercicio con el pack tracer.
Vale,
vale,
vale. Está voy a marcarlo como que lo
hemos visto. Sí que sí que
profundizaremos aquí en los
en esto. Vale, añadir comentario.
es 30
del 9 del 2025.
todo
y vamos a ver.
Vale, el ejercicio vamos a [__] el
cuatro que está en la está en la
plataforma.
¿Lo veis? ¿No lo podéis lo podéis ver?
Sí, sí, está aquí.
Vale, espera, lo voy a descargar yo.
Bueno, realmente lo tenía descargado,
pero
vale, sería una red de cuatro
ordenadores conectados mediante un
switch.
O sea, es
no es complejo.
En los ejercicios es que no lo recuerdo.
En el 1, dos y 3 no utilizabais switch,
¿verdad? en ninguno.
Vale, abrimos paquet tracer.
Y el ejercicio lo tenemos aquí.
Sí,
de verdad que lo de Zunis es un
incorpio, ¿eh?
Vale, este y este aquí.
Vale, procedemos en primer lugar a, o
sea, lo que vamos a hacer es una red de
cuatro ordenadores conectados mediante
mediante un switch.
Podemos en primer lugar, o sea,
procedemos en primer lugar a diseñar la
red de cuatro ordenadores con con las
especificaciones que nos piden.
Vale, ese el switch no lo habéis usado
en los en los anteriores. Vosotros,
Álvaro, o sea, los que venís de del año
pasado sí que habréis toqueteado Sis y y
servidores y de todo, imagino.
Vale, el único elemento nuevo que no se
ha usado en trabajos anteriores es el
switch genérico, el cual está ubicado en
el apartado switch. Solo deberemos
seleccionar seleccionar el icono, bueno,
este de aquí, o sea, aquí nos venimos
aquí y aquí, ¿vale? genérico. Entiendo
que es este.
Seguidamente el icono de su genérico se
la mano en la captura de que se muestra
continua y finalmente arrastarlo a la
zona de trabajo. Vale, seleccionamos,
nos soltamos con el botón izquierdo
ratón y lo soltamos en medio de la
pantalla
donde vamos a diseñar la red.
Aquí realmente está cogiendo, está
cogiendo este del medio. A ver,
noos genérico, eh,
switch pt.
Es que como es otra versión,
aquí sí que lo tienen como genérico,
pero aquí no lo tenemos.
Podría ser este.
Vamos a [__] ese.
Y vamos a poner este también de aquí por
si acaso. A ver qué diferencias hay
en la cantidad de puertos.
Vale, sí, es la cantidad de puertos
básicamente.
Tiene gigabit
y este no lo tiene.
Vale, vamos a usar este primero que está
así como más más
modernillo,
¿vale? Usamos este, ¿vale? El el 2960,
¿vale? Lo siguiente, siguiente paso,
colocar los ordenar los ordenadores,
renombrarlos y asignar direcciones IP.
Se sigue el protocol el procedimiento ya
descrito en el trabajo uno de tal forma
que la red de cuatro ordeados
interconectados por un switch de quede
de la siguiente manera. ¿Vale? A ver,
cogemos
eh nos vamos a este icono de aquí,
a la dispositivos finales
y ponemos cuatro PCs.
1 creo que los han llamado PC11,
¿vale? Y les cambiamos nombre.
PC11.
A ver.
Eh,
sí, PC.
A ver, PC11,
PC 1 2,
PC
13,
PC 14.
Vale. Eh, y les ponemos la
A ver, los conectamos. A ver. para
renombrarlos y asignar direcciones IP.
Se sigue el procedimiento ya descrito en
el trabajo uno, de tal forma que las red
de cuatro ordenadores se interconectan
de la siguiente manera, ¿vale? O sea,
vamos a poner, vamos a añadir, vamos a
conectarlos.
Lo podemos hacer de dos maneras, forma
automática,
pinchamos en el rayo
y a continuación pinchamos en el rayito
este de del desplegable,
pinchamos en el dispositivo de final y
luego al switch, ¿vale? y él ya nos lo
nos lo instal automáticamente. O bien lo
podemos hacer de forma manual, que es
venirnos aquí al cable,
elegir el puerto de salida del
ordenador, que solo tiene uno,
o sea, el puerto de la tarjeta de la
tarjeta de R del ordenador que solo
tiene uno. Y nos venimos aquí y
elegimos, pues por ejemplo este primero.
Aquí hacemos lo propio.
Elegimos el segundo,
elegimos el tercero.
Ay, perdón, es esto de aquí. Y aquí
elegimos el cuarto. Vale, a continuación
le añadimos las direcciones IP
de cada cable cable directo del Switch
correspondiente. Se ha renombrado los PT
y asignado la configuración IP. Vamos a
asignarles la configuración IP. Esto
sería el 11 sería el 192 16811.
¿Cómo lo hacemos? Tenemos dos opciones,
nos ponemos venir aquí y aquí en IP
configuración y se y se lo añadimos. Se
lo ponemos aquí.
Bueno, vamos a hacerlo en este aquí. 192
pun 168.1.1.
Y cuando pincha, o sea, le damos a intro
o pinchamos en el en la máscara de
subred, ya nos añade automáticamente la
máscara de subred.
Esto sería una red de clase C. Esto lo
veremos también que sí que es material
de de esta que lo vamos a ver en breve.
Vale, cerramos. Y este ya lo tenemos con
esta IP.
¿Veis aquí? Bueno, pues que no si muevo
el ratón se va se va la ventana. Pero
veis que que tiene esa red,
tiene esa IPA. Vale, nos vamos al
segundo y tenemos otro método para para
añadirle. Antes nos hemos venido aquí a
IP configuración y hemos pinchado aquí
en la configuración IP,
¿vale? Pero ahora vamos a hacerlo a
través de aquí de de esta otra pestaña.
Nos venimos aquí
y en estático le ponemos, o sea, en el
fastnet la la tarjeta de red sería,
¿vale? Aquí también podemos,
bueno, eso sería la no
nos venimos aquí a la tarjeta de red y
le decimos que en estática es
subdirección IPv4
sería la 192.68.1
pun
y nos calculan la máscara de sub.
que en este caso pues es lo mismo, es la
misma que la que la otra, pertenece al a
la misma clase.
Vale, cerramos.
Vale, nos venimos aquí.
192.168.1.3.
Cerramos y nos venimos aquí. Lo hacemos
de la otra manera.
nos nos venimos aquí y aquí le ponemos
192.168.1.4
[Música]
y nos calcula la máscara de su vale y
cerramos. ¿Vale?
Cuando haya realizado la conexión,
cuando hayas realizado la conexión,
prueba a realizar un pinqu
de equipos y prueba
que funciona, ¿vale?
Tenemos que este es el
este es
192 168 1
y este es
192 168 14. Vamos a hacer un pin al este
primer
desde este primero, desde desde el PC11
al PC 14. ¿Vale? ¿Cómo lo hacemos? Nos
venimos aquí.
O sea, pinchamos, pinchamos sobre el
sobre el dispositivo, nos aparece la
ventana de de su configuración,
nos venimos aquí
al terminal,
le decimos pin
a1
92.168.1.4.
Y si no nos si no nos da error es que se
puede comunicar con él, ¿vale? Y nos
está diciendo que le ha mandado
cuatro cuatro paquetes y se han recibido
los cuatro. Se han perdido cero. Vale,
entonces es óptimo. Es óptima la
comisión es correcta.
Vale, podemos hacer pin del 13.
al
a este de aquí, por ejemplo.
Este, ¿cuál tendría? La 1 pun
1.2.
Vale, esta es la 1.2.
Entonces, hacemos un pin desde el 13 al
12. El 13 tiene la 1.3 y vamos a hacer
un pin a la 1.2. O sea, os digo el
final, eh, la terminación de la
de su dirección IP para no repetir todo
el rato 192 tal. Vale, le damos y tiene
comunicación. Vale, perfecto. Ha enviado
cuatro,
se han recibido cuatro y se han perdido
cero.
Vale, bien. El tiempo un milisegundo,
o sea, está muy bien. Vale,
vale. En este apartado variantes sobre
cuando hayas realizado conexión, prueba
a realizar un Tenemos la red correcta,
¿vale? Tenemos que, hombre, no hemos
hecho uno de aquí a aquí, pero vamos,
tampoco tiene mayor sentido. O sea,
podíamos hacer del tres
al 4 y 192.168.1.4.
[Música]
Y bueno, vemos que funciona también,
¿vale?
Ya os queda claro cómo se hace un pin,
cómo se utiliza la consola,
¿vale? Serían las opciones aquí,
¿vale? Y ahí le ponemos ya las es como a
ver si creo que eh config,
¿vale? ¿Veis? Si le ponemos el IP confit
también y también nos dice nos da todos
los todos los datos relativos a la red
de ese de ese ordenador.
O sea, realmente es que solo tiene esto,
tiene su su dirección que sería la 1.1 y
su máscara de su red.
No hay nada más configurado, no nos
puede dar más más información.
Vale, supongamos que queremos enviar un
pin del esto. Con ello hacemos que
empiece un esto es lo que hemos hecho.
La pestaña. Bueno, ahí tenéis las
instrucciones, ¿vale? Os pone aquí un
circulito donde tenéis que que pinchar,
¿vale? Obtendemos entonces la interfaz
de línea de comandos y tecleamos 192, o
sea, pink 192 168 14. Mira, esto lo
podéis hacer también a
venimos aquí.
cmd, no sé si lo hemos hecho en otras
clases.
Podemos decir hm pink, esto ya estamos
en el ordenador a
punto comom, por ejemplo.
No sé si me va a dejar. Sí, sí que me
debería dejar. Vale, o sea, te le estás
diciendo, "Vale, le he enviado cuatro, o
sea, comunicación, le he enviado cuatro,
he recibido cuatro, he perdido cero." O
sea, realmente es una ¿Con quién nos
hemos comunicado? Con este señor, que
¿quién es este señor? El servidor de de
Google,
¿vale? Esta es su dirección, la que nos
ha tocado a nosotros.
másamos
un ping
al
8.8.8.8,
que sería el servidor de DNS de Google y
también tenemos respuesta,
¿vale? O sea, esto es eh esto es para
probar la comunicación entre entre
equipos. Un equipo es el servidor de de
DNS de Google. Lo que pasa es claro, o
sea, hm es un equipo
con todas palabras, o sea, con todas las
letras.
Vale, obtenemos la dirección IP. Como
podemos observar, se han enviado cuatro
paquetes, recibió cuatro y no se ha
perdido ninguno. Por lo tanto, la
comunicación ha sido correcta.
Fíjate que ahora además de los paquetes
ICM aparece un nuevo tipo de paquete que
es ARP. Destaca esta novedad en tu
memoria.
Ah, vale, es para esto. Es el ejercicio,
¿vale?
nos aparece un nuevo tipo de paquete.
Destaca y explica de forma sencilla qué
utiliza tienes del protocolo para una
mayor claridad y combustibles usos para
programas complejos señalar que Paquetra
permite editar filtros
para poder visualizar sobre los paquetes
que nos interesan. en este caso
concreto, ICM, P y RP. Para ello, en la
pestaña simulación pulso en el botón
edit filters.
Vale, vale.
A ver. Vale, nos venimos aquí. Espera,
¿dónde está?
Nos vamos aquí a simulación. editar
filtros. Vale, se refiere a esto,
¿vale? Estamos hablando de ICMP DNS.
Desactivamos todos
estos y únicamente nos quedamos con
esto. Vale,
cerramos
y vamos a enviar, por ejemplo,
vamos a enviar de aquí
de este a este,
pero claro, en modo simulación
que no vamos a hacerlo en tiempo real.
A ver que lo voy a poner en grandoteos
aquíamos
aquí
y se ha se ha enviado con éxito. Nos
tenemos aquí a simulación.
¿Veis
la diferencia con los hubs con con los
con los dispositivos de que estuvimos
mirando en los en los demás ejercicios?
Aquí te manda el paquete únicamente al
que al que lo tiene recibir. ¿Por qué?
Porque este dispositivo ya lo encauza
hacia donde tiene que ir, no va hacia
todos.
Vale, pinchamos aquí en el paquete
y aquí tenemos los detalles.
Deberíamos detener.
La siguiente capa que es lo que
estábamos mirando fuera de
marco.
A ver qué es lo que nos pida el
ejercicio, por ejemplo.
Vale, pues no se para poner
editar los filtros son los paquetes que
nos interesan.
Vale, ya estamos en simulación.
desactivamos todo. Se podría hacer lo
mismo con pero pues un requisito se deja
como elemento esta
operaciones de filtrado,
¿vale?
Seará lo que ocurre en nuestro modelo
con y explicar la utilidad que tiene
este protocolo. Nos situamos en modo
simulación de pared y cerrar un paquete
del 12 al 13.
Vale, veamos como aparecen dos paquetes,
un ICM y una RP para que se utilización
[Música]
estuvimos viendo el tema de ARP
al principio.
Al principio, ¿verdad? A mí sí que me
suena que estuvimos
o o esto lo hemos estado viendo en
segundo.
A mí no me suena mucho.
No te suena, ¿verdad? Esto lo estuvimos
bien segundo.
que realmente es un ejercicio de
segundo.
Hm.
A ver, podíamos eh el RP es una es algo
así como una búsqueda del
del
destinatario filtrando la MAC, la
dirección MAC, ¿vale?, del del
destinatario.
Es que sería algo así, ¿vale? Entonces,
eh
el que tiene tiene esta tiene esa
dirección IP, sería algo así,
¿vale? Sería una búsqueda de lo de donde
va el destino mediante la maca
groso modo.
Vale, si queréis
lo dejamos lo dejamos aquí y nos ponemos
con la con la siguiente
que sería
sistemas.
Sí. Mm.
Vale, vamos a dejarlo aquí porque creo
que se nos, o sea, una cosa es empezar a
utilizar el el paquet tracer y otra vez
meternos ya en harina de
que no que no tiene, o sea, vamos
primero a entender conceptos de vamos
poco a poco también,
¿vale? a ir mirando el temario y luego
llegaremos a esto, por supuesto.
Vale,
cierro
tengo grabación. M.